welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar detection and
interpretation of complex myeloid
leukemia mutations presented by dr.
Veronique lalu who is the senior global
product manager of personalized
healthcare oncology act hi Jen and dr.
Beyonce listen Berger who is the product
owner of kyochon clinical insight
interpret my name is Xavier Gutierrez
and I will be your moderator for today's
event we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by kyochon for more
information about our sponsor please
visit www.thegrape.com box our speaker
will respond to your questions via email
following the presentation and if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem and this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. la Lu and dr.
Liston Berger I will now turn the
presentation over to them
thank you in this webinar we introduced
two solutions for the detection and
interpretation of mutations associated
with myeloid malignancies and it is my
pleasure to present you today hydrants
integrated sample to inside NGS clinical
research workflow for detection of
myeloid mutations here is I our
disclaimer the gene reader NGS system
and associated products including the
kayak my Louie DNA umi panel and QC are
interpret for gene reader are for
researchers only they are not for
diagnostic use so what prevents
laboratories from realizing the promise
of NGS the main hurdles are the
fragmented workflow first different
products different technologies from
different vendors you never know how
well they work together secondly
analyzing and interpreting the data
complex NGS raw data analyzes -
reporting requires bioinformatics
resources and high cost comp it's
complex and tedious to get the total
talk to a total cost of ownership
particularly with fragmented workflow so
how is the gene reader NGS system
different by providing simple workflow
seamless by informatics and
cost-effectiveness with predictable
costs I would like here to share one
laboratories experience testimonial in
using gene reader NGS system professors
at local from medical university of
cards explains that combining different
product from different companies you
never know how well they will function
together and that one tends to
underestimate the true cost of running
NGS not considering the cost
Nancy and pricey optimizations serega a
he expects to see a major advantage from
a fully integrated workflow like the
gene reader NGS system
this teen read ramjet system is the
first truly complete NGS solution from
nucleic acid extraction all the way to
interpretation
with kya gen automation solutions like
kiyah cube or kaya symphony for the
sample preparation and qci for the
bioinformatics thus the work so includes
quality control steps which are crucial
in NGS support is provided with
step-by-step digital guide engine read
assistant and data management is also
considered with an optional gene with
link and gene read data bank offering
everything needed from one vendor for
NGS solutions
the gene reader sequencer with three
flow cells behave like three sequences
in one scaling up and down each flow
cell depending on the number of samples
but also with a continuous loading of so
cell you don't have to wait for one to
end before starting a new one
with the secondary bioinformatics
analyzes qci analyze you have intuitive
and flexible variant calling and
visualizations variance quality control
and various metrics are listed in clear
tables variance can also be visualized
in a genome track viewer
agem acquired several bioinformatics
companies to provide seamless solutions
including tertiary assessment with 20
years experience in curation and
knowledge-based compilation based on
kiya-jaye knowledgebase QC i interpret
provides intuitive and transparent
variant interpretation designed built
and verified in collaboration with
clinical research labs the relevant
insights are in like basic variants
characteristic such as function
frequency effect on protein and more
everything is geared towards the
ultimate objective an actionable report
with the essentials the report provides
information about variant
characteristics based on AMT ASCO car
guidelines and this report is
customizable with the relevant
information information from the
variants at your discretion
so in summary an integrated NGS system
workflow allows you to avoid the pain of
amazing upstream solutions save the
expanse of specialized resources to
develop and optimize a bioinformatics
pipeline realize a true solution with
sequence of performance that's pre
verified within an entire workflow
optimize the efficiency of your
laboratory with an automated workflow
management and data handling solution
and finally document the full chain of
custody from sample to inside
the Chi Act panel portfolio includes
five of the shelf panels for oncology
and the very first panel for on caja
mythology we also offer custom panel
using the same technology as catalog
panels but customizing the content and
the PIAT bioinformatics solution to the
laboratories needs
this table summarizes the plexi sample
material and applications per panel and
today's focus is on the kayak my Luigi
and I do a my panel which flexing is
from one to eight samples maximum pop so
cell from blood or bone marrow the
library automation on tire cube is not
available but this is working progress
the kayak melete DNA um a panel is for
molecular characterization for the
presence of the clonal myeloid neoplasm
targeting the different myeloid cell
types NPN and ian's the overlapping MDS
NPN AML and systemic mastocytosis we
have gone through an optimized panel
design process with high quality and
demanding care requirements
starting with sample preparation we
wanted to give the maximum flexibility
to laboratories with the choice of
either the manual DNA extraction or an
automated gene extraction using either
Kyah cube or kiya symphony from blood
and bone marrow samples once extracted
you start from 14 anagram of genomic DNA
in put the panel incorporates umi
technology for increased accuracy and
analytical sensitivity 25 genes of known
significance to clonal myeloid
malignancies have been selected with
internationally known Oklahoma Tala G
experts and this genomic region covers
about 9000 previously reported variants
believed to be pathogenic the panel
allows to report snv and indel variants
one of the key requirements which is a
known challenge to NGS is the detection
of large in they'll typically detecting
the color type one which is a 50 to be
spelled elation and their faulty three
ITD's with the identified insertion site
we have set ask a requirement three
different allowed analytical sensitivity
cut-offs a 1% variant allele frequency
for jak 2 and keep jeans 0.4% variant
allele frequency for the kid D 816
mutation and the classical 5% valve for
the rest of the panel the Q th sisindri
mutation sensitivity of 0.3 cent is
important because extremely low burden
of blood circulating cells there this
mutation in systemic mastocytosis
samples another challenge for NGS is
gc-rich content so we have set as a
minimum requirement to be able to cover
90% of GDP as a gene as it is a complete
sample to inside si this is integrated
as part of the gene reader entire system
including full bioinformatics analysis
and reporting tailored and optimized for
this si the total turnaround time from
the sample to insights from the RO
samples to the final report including
DNA extraction is maximum 5 working days
and we wanted also to give the
flexibility to combine multiple kayak
DNA umi panel on the same flow cell for
maximum operational efficiency
this table lists the 25 genes and
regions covered by the CAG marry DNA you
are my panel including full coding
region for several genes for example MPL
covers the full coding region and not
only the example hotspot mutations in
this least the exome numbers are
according to the transcript ID listed
here exome member may differ with a
different transcript ID for example in
some publications you will see four NPM
one exon 12 with a different transcript
ID but discover at the end the same
biological region as exon 11 with this
listed transcript ID
we wanted this panel to be a core and
myeloid panel targeting markers of known
significance to myeloid malignancies
including the most common mutations
across the diverse subtypes as you can
see here from this it map of mutation
frequency per subtype we increased the
assay performance through the umi
technology Umi is a short sequence or
barcode added to each original DNA
molecule before any amplification so
these enables the identification and
further removal of false positive
variant introduced by teacher artifacts
by preserving the uniqueness of the
original molecule so we have a true
digital sequencing with super rich
here I would like to spend some time to
explain the particular settings that
have been implemented in key CI analyzed
specifically for the kayak my Luigi in a
way my panel due to the spatial three
analytical sensitivity cut-offs so for
coverage thresholds have been set three
different significant coverage
thresholds depending on the three
sensitivity cut-offs
so 500x um I to detect the valve 0.4%
5816 denudation
200 X um I to detect vas at 1% injector
and kitchens and 100 gifts um I to
detect the graph at 5% for the rest of
the panel the minimum coverage threshold
is common and at 44 it's um I so a
variant which has a coverage threshold
above the significant coverage threshold
will be automatically validated in the
table 3.1 of QC I analyzed for inclusion
in VCF results and a close to QC I
interpret variants which are having
coverage between the minimum and the
significant covered threshold will be
populating the table 3.2 of QC I
analyzed for review and these variants
can manually be moved to table 3.1 at
the users discretion and any position
which drops below the minimum coverage
threshold of 44 X um I will be listed in
table 3.3 as not detected
so following the development efforts we
have verified the keep requirements set
for this essay so starting with the one
percent sensitivity an electrical
sensitivity cutoff
we have successfully detected a 1%
accuracy 17 s mutation so this
analytical sensitivity of the system is
in line with the commonly accepted 1%
positivity cutoff for this mutation
another high sensitivity has been
successfully reached with detecting
ecliptic 16v even at a point when t7000
variant allele frequency showing a
highly sensitive system reliably
detecting this key TX 16 denotation
now coming to large deletion we
successfully detected with the system
the color type 1 the 52 base pair
deletion showing the ability of the SI
to detect challenging large deletions
and also large insertions we have
successfully detected flt3 ITD's up to
204 days clear insertion and like for
any other variants the variant allele
frequency is listed in the qci table but
also the exact position of the insertion
which is also relevant
so here again showing the ability of the
system and the SI to detect challenging
large insertions we have gone through a
thorough and rigid sample to inside
verification with the highest level that
includes multiple experiments multiple
instruments users and sites and review
on each subtype and sub subsystem and
system levels before going to release a
catalog panel that like the [ __ ]
mileage in EMI panel
in peace table are summarized the key
performances outcome of the verification
perform on 256 samples so the region
event of interest coverage is 32
kilobase the multiplexing has been
confirmed with a maximum of 8 samples
per flow cell and overall high
flexibility and excellent metrics have
been shown for all genes the specificity
is excellent with 99% map reads the Q
score is also very good and the coverage
of the regions of interest have been
drilled down based on the sensitivity
cut-offs ninety nine ninety nine point
eight percent for 100x um I at five
percent off a hundred percent for two
hundred x um I for the two gene subsets
at one percent vos more than two
thousand it's you my for the TTT 816 D
and for CBP alpha between the minimum
and the significant covered threshold we
have reached 97% at the minimum and 86%
at the significant coverage threshold
for CBP alpha coverage of note a 28 days
pure interval of EB Piazza gene can drop
below the 44 X um I covered threshold
and we disclosed in the handbook the
exact position of this interval
we further drill down the verification
process per variance category and
analytical sensitivity levels we used
reference samples horizon Sarah Kia the
w-h-o drag to the 617 as reference
material cell lines and biological blood
samples to verify the detection and the
coding of variants so I won't go into
each detail of this drill down but
overall you can see from each PPA and
PPV values that we have reached a high
level of analytical sensitivity and
analytical precision even at the global
accuracy the global accuracy is
excellent with 99.99 percent and the
multi lot multi operators multi
instruments precision is also very good
we confirm the true total turnaround
time fall from eight samples which is
maximum five working days so this has
been done thoroughly with our MD and a
timer to be able to claim these five
working days of turnaround time a
particular particular node for flt3
ITD's which is detected up to 204 base
care we also informing the handbook that
for insertions longer than 177 base pair
insertions depending on the experimental
conditions you may or may not be
detecting these
so summarizing the key highlights of the
CAG Malloy DNA Umi panel in one slide
the panel targets 25 genes of known
significance to my load malignancies
covering genomic regions containing
approximately 9,000 variants reported to
be pathogenic high analytical
sensitivity detection of variants inject
to encrypt genes with a 1% variant
allele frequency keep 3 816 D 0.4%
variant allele frequency enabled by
digital sequencing using Umi technology
detection of challenging mutations
including a 33 ITD's color relations and
CBP alpha mutations sample input as low
as 40 nano gram DNA extracted from blood
and bone marrow flexibility multiple chi
continue my panels may be combined on
the same cell cell and automated
analyzes integrated bioinformatics
interpretation and reporting with QC i
all of this is built on the success of
the eight surgeon product portfolio
leveraging courage and extensive
knowledge of blood cancers so coming
back to the challenges listed at the
very beginning of this presentation to
implement NGS here is how courage and
solution addresses this barrier with the
first truly complete NGS workflow from a
single vendor actionable insights
creating relevant reports using Chiron's
proven gene panels and preeminent by
informatics platform flexibility to fit
your needs with scalability depending on
batch sizes and continuous loading of
multiple flow cells
warrantied results with predictable
costs expertise and service with the
world while
Network this is the end of the clinical
research application part and I would
like now to hand over to my colleague
Beata for QC I interpret also available
as clinical decision support thank you
you
thank you so much Veronique so let's
shift the focus on the tertiary variant
analysis which is the interpretation and
recording of variants using the QC I
interpret platform
this is a formality to disclaimer
hydrent clinical insight interpret is
also available as clinical decision
support software
so cute interpret enables maps to
deliver evidence-based insights for any
indication across rare and territory
diseases predatory cancers oncology and
haematology
today we're going to focus on how QC I
interpret provides biological relevant
insights into variance from
hematological malignancy
so this is a high-level overview of the
various features of QC I interpret 50 I
interpret assists in the computation and
recording of operations
it is based on a comprehensive content
knowledge phase which allow KCI to
display the alterations biology report
clinical cases prognostic outcome
treatments and trials for the particular
alterations of interest in the context
of the user and the disease phenotype
so therefore the Qi platform allows you
to answer important questions what are
the biological characteristics of this
alteration is a clinical relevance and
is it actionable
interpret compute the biological
relevant and actuality according to the
ACMG and M guidelines for alteration
classic equations and because this
removes the need for time-consuming
manual research CCI provides the lab
with its scalable automated
interpretation solution
and the last point here is that people
interpret platform provides the user the
option to customize the final report and
it can be configured towards the lab
specific needs which may include less
specific recording policies tests
specific variants pre-filtering or the
integration with other existing lab
pipelines all that helps the labs
automate standardize and scale the NGS
sequencing solution
so what situation are we facing when
interpreting a somatic alterations so
many many resources are needed to gather
the information and understand the
biological relevance of an alteration
and that means we have to sift through
public and corporately databases to see
this variant has been seen before in the
disease context just miss it to a
handful of sources we also have to dig
into the published literature that
describes the function of the mutation
its role in tumor Genesis association
with the disease and the potential use
of variants varied prediction tools to
predictability richness of mutation
so on top of that we have to also review
indications on drug labels a constantly
changing guideline recommendations
clinical trials and dig further into the
primary literature to provide insights
into the action ability of an alteration
and that causes obvious challenges that
we need to overcome first efficiency
this is a manual curation process and
it's laborious and time-consuming second
its accuracy as with any manual process
it can be error-prone especially if no
standardized curation protocol and
semantic consistency is used and then
they posed another challenge scalability
the number of articles that describe an
alteration in context of a disease
outcome or therapeutic response has
increased fourfold during the past ten
years and that would basically need to
hire an army of scientists to keep the
very encouraged to keep up with the
varrock turistic which leads to the
challenge of being comprehensive in
content as a reasonable amount of cost
hydron has simplified this process by
putting all of this information in one
centralized location known as the kaijin
knowledge base
the courage and knowledge base called
more than 21 million findings and that
ranges from an alteration disease
association to an alteration drug
response Association and that stands for
more than 30,000 publications
to ensure an up-to-date knowledge base
the content is updated smoothly on a
weekly basis which allows us to cope
with the increasing number of literature
sources and changing information from
label clinical files and guidelines
the amount of external databases that
you have to review when interpreting a
parent is tremendous
the Kaiser knowledgebase incorporates
thirty-one external publicly or
proprietary databases and twenty-five of
cells that are listed here in the
screenshots are used in queue to
interpret
with respect to the therapeutic
actionability as of today we have more
than 13,000 manually curated alteration
pipes you have response disease
associations across a variety of
indications that support the therapeutic
action ability increased interpret
I also want to point out that the
knowledgebase provides world wide open
and recruiting clinical trials where
biomarker requires files provide access
to investigational drugs addressed
across more than four thousand and five
hundred thirty indication
to access the prognostic relevance of an
alteration which is a particular
interest in hematological malignancy the
keidel knowledge base covered content on
a variety of my life neoplasms such as
acute myeloid leukemia college
lymphocytic leukemia meiosis moodle
plastic syndrome and my smile of
proliferation and your presence
so how is it possible that CCI interpret
can match evidence from the literature
to compute the alteration catification
in context of specific disease
so this is accomplished through a unique
knowledge based model and I want to
spend just a few minutes to explain that
model
so extra curators which are PhD and MD
level read the scientific literature
including bigger table supplementary
information and add each alterations
clinical effect Association into a
structured format that I'm highlighting
here and that structured format is in
our knowledge base so this structured
format is obviously not human readable
so we use natural language generation
processing on top of this knowledge base
to model this into a sentence which
returns them the essence of an
experiment or clinical trial results
from a paper and that it's human
readable again
so this unstructured data from the
various sources is now continued
consistently structured with semantic
consistency in the ontology and this is
done across the different sources that
are highlighted to the right top
so we can now use rule based algorithm
the dance can be used on top of the
structured data in our knowledge base to
automatically trigger the pathogenicity
criteria such as a CSV rule or axe
ability criteria such as t1 or t2
actualities
so to say interpret as I mentioned
before compute the the pathogenicity and
actionability according to guidelines so
you see interpret is compliant with the
guidelines for interpreting operations
the underlined guidelines that assess
the biological relevance are based on
the ACMG guidelines and QC interpret
provides three actionability
classifications based on the ancestral
cup guidelines
so how is the information from the
knowledgebase displayed in to interpret
and due to the limited time I want to
highlight here a few key features that
particularly provide the biological and
actionable insights into alterations
detected implement illogical malignancy
so what you can see here on the screen
is a variant list of an envious result
of an acute myeloid specimen sample each
tile represents an operation detected in
a tumor and the different color codes
that you can see here to the left such
as red green or brain display the QC i
computed pathogenicity of an alteration
and the left corner indicates the QC i
computed actionability specification
so this year basically provides a broad
overview of the station molecular
profiles and allows various filtering to
provide height the alteration that would
meet a deeper review
so when you click on one of those tasks
it allows the user to rapidly assess the
biological relevance of an alteration
for each variant GV occupies front and
center and assessment section which
displays the actionability criteria and
pathogenicity criteria that are
automatically triggered like you see
interpret
the user is able to immediately review
the description of the ACMG criteria as
well as review the underlying scientific
evidence that supports this criteria
just one thing I would like to note is
that the user has filled full control of
adjusting the pathogenicity criteria by
removing or adding a criterion or
adjusting the strength of the criteria
and adding any notes why this was done
that provides the user full control over
the Kramnik the final assessment
for example a functional consequence of
an alterations and the easily assessed
by clicking on the info icon to gain a
snapshot if this operation has been
characterized in the literature
and reviewing the underlying evidence of
the piously rule which refers to
established in vitro or in vivo
functional ethics the user can review
the underlying publication but also can
review the location of an operation in
an important functional domain or in an
exon relative to the whole gene so that
the users able to simultaneously review
the a duration of interest in context of
other pathogenic mutation
for those operations where the function
is less clear we associate creation of
the specific mutation in the disease of
interest might be another way to check
more light into the role of the mutation
so in this case the user has the ability
to vote in you the alteration
associations with the disease in the
assessment section as well as in more
details in the reported clinical cases
section
so in my previous two slides now I have
only touched upon a few features that
are available for each variants
what you can see here in the screenshot
is that for each alteration that is
detected in the patient profiles PC I
interpret provides a non stop shop
organized in several expandable sections
for the users review depressed
information about the operation in the
use in the context of the user submitted
phenotype
and I will key feature to interpret
mutation from hematological malignancies
is to rapidly access the somatic
frequency for the alterations in context
of the diagnosis
the other operations are frequencies
dynamic based on the selected phenotype
and in cases where the submitted patient
diagnosis is a hematological cancer as
it is in the case here the
myelodysplastic syndrome the music can
rapidly assess the somatic frequency
across a list of similarity
methodological cancer which are aligned
with the wh4 classification
so especially if the etiology of the
hematological malignancies and circles
it is important to readily determine if
the alteration may be rare in the
patient's diagnosis but it's frequent in
another theme of illogical cancer
select focus on the action abilities
here
all ships that are applicable will be
shown in the assessment section as you
can see here
for each tears the underlying clinical
evidence of Candy's views and this
provides transparency in the sources
that support each tier
for the Fiorina capabilities the user
can go and each side into the treatment
section which lists treatment and the
associate level of evidence in the
context of the specific operation and
tumor types
the treatment section allows the user to
choose the Associated treatment and also
clinical trials to be added to the final
record I also want to point out that the
user has full flexibility to both around
clinical trials according to the
specificity location and space and then
select those for inclusion on the final
report
for alterations that have been detected
in hematological cancer epi interpret
enables users to evaluate the prognosis
of relevance of the alteration in
context of them are submitted phenotype
again here the user has full
transparency to the underlying evidence
and can choose to include this
information on the final record
for alterations that have been described
as a major diagnostic criteria in the
WTO guidelines for the classification of
Milo's neoplasms and acute leukemia qci
provides in the assessment section if
such information is applicable to the
user-submitted phenotype
after reviewing the information in the
bare details page the users able to set
the final assessment of the alteration
and in this section the user has the
ability to report out the pathogenicity
and/or actionability for each operation
and that highlighted by the red box here
so before generating a final report the
review and reports page that are shown
here in the screenshot provides you with
a summary of the informations marked as
reportable during the assessment process
and provides features to complete the
report building process manage and
review the process and generate the
report so for a duration that are marked
as reportable in this screenshot is the
flip 3 mutation and the sequel our
mutation you see I can automatically
generate an interpretive comment which
contains information about the gene the
alteration functions they're physically
relevant which saves the users
time-consuming manual work the user can
also review reported stress and review
PPI generated your comments which can be
edited as well
the change state button allows you to
manage the review process of the test
and then when it's ready to sign out you
just click the sign up button last but
not least before signing else you might
want to review the end result of your
NGS solution which is a report with
detailed actionable insights that record
is fully customizable with the relevant
variant information including the ACMG
Papa genetically and an action ability
and relevance drugs a clinical false
prognostic information and a
customizable interpretive comment
laughs I also want to point out that
customers can submit cytogenetic results
as you can see here in this screenshot
to facilitate the interpretation of
variance in context of the paramedic
event
the design separate platform has been
validated by very support for you and I
want to draw your attention to the right
graphics this map has highlighted the
time-saving aspect when analyzing rare
variants were estimated across 50
patient samples time savings of up to
78% when using keychain service compared
to experts and culture-negative curation
you can interpret results have also been
validated across a set of 50 patients
with myeloid malignancies with a
component of 87% percent between the
manual curation versus CGI computer
classification and this is the normal
range range of discordance that exists
among experts are the various literature
that have been examining this and the
controversy regarding the consistency of
classifications exists in other
databases such as clinvar but there's
also no strong discordance calls between
the mismatched arm of a pathogenic nt9
variant and the conclusion of this lab
is that the differences are due to
scarce public data and was largely sleep
largely due to in health knowledge base
summarize the key values of society
interpret any lab can immediately adopt
the ACMG or amp guidelines for
interpretation and recording
geez interpret automates the guidelines
provided every lab scalable standardized
rep reducible NGS interpretation and
reporting solution any lab can
confidently interpret and report the
pathogenicity and action ability because
the platform provides full transparency
to every piece of scientific evidence
the platform is configurable
customizable and flexible with regards
to integration with lab systems for a
seamless of interpretation workflow thus
please interpret enable fast analysis of
yourself sustainable operations
interpretations and reporting
thank you so much for your attention
thank you dr. lelou and dr. Watson
burger for that informative presentation
I would also like to thank agent for
making today's educational webcast
possible and as a final reminder our
speakers will follow up with any
questions you submitted via email well
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon
goodbye